the Rams quarterback Jared golf on the
program Jared thanks for joining us
how's morale today good good yeah you
watch the game footage from or watch the
film from the Falcons game yeah we
watched it and it's you know definitely
disappointing and not where we want to
end by any means but ultimately a really
good game I mean they control the talked
mostly game control the ball we were
unable to get much gone offensively you
know the baby is very well let surprised
you the most about Falcons I don't think
anything surprised as we were hit we
know we're getting you know if I get
defense I pass rush they value the ball
well and offensively you know if you had
the best often elite last year for a
reason and by Ryan specially on all our
backs so now we know exactly we're
getting old I guess I think they fight
really well and you know I'll scan to us
and they're all good things if I would
have told you at the beginning of the
year you're going to be 11 in five
you're gonna win the division but you're
gonna lose in your first playoff game
would you have signed up for that you
know now it's now it's hard to say so I
think it's so first you start to this
idea whether or not you're happy with it
especially you know when they're still
playing and those teams still playing
that we have beat this year and so it's
hard you know what that painters darling
but you know I think there's a lot of
things I did this year that were very
happy with but you know dip your way
that is a step in the right direction
and it's a step into a building and
winning culture and some of it stuff
that we're happy about but you know but
no means right now are we are we happy
about what what's the big difference
between the first year in the second
year for you I think just like any other
level you know you go through high
school college I thought everything so
that you start to get more comfortable
and you're in your second year the first
year you're just not feeling things a
second you start so anything and so on
so forth through the rest of your career
as the years go on it just becomes more
comfortable and more second nature you
you're faced but I think eight playoff
tra let me see you played Jaguars
Vikings Saints Eagles and of course the
alkanes best defense you face this year
was who out of that group ooh-ooh
I think I think personnel-wise the
Jaguars I think overall defense minister
what about Jackson stuff how would you
describe Minnesota's defense there's no
weakness they're good at every spot
there's a mmm and when you play in
Minnesota
like we're going through this week and
we we've been excited too because we're
there earlier here you know has an idea
of the atmosphere there it's tough to
win there it's not the one with an
opposing female it you know we were
excited to hopefully get the chance
what about the Jags secondary is that
that the strength even though you got
Lance Campbell no let's see again better
good at every spot I think you know
there's our corners less horns in the
league with those two guys and I believe
and my second area that get a probably
good pass Russian you know we played it
we played a really good game right then
we played that we're lucky tomorrow they
went east Jared Goff the Rams
quarterback joining us Dan Patrick show
for people who didn't see Aaron Donald
at the beginning of the year just to see
him against the Falcons
like man you're really lucky you don't
have to face him in practice where he
gets to hit you jerk I see what he does
I see he does you know sometimes I'll
just watch him like one more on the
sidelines looking at the camels now look
at the scoreboard watch and sometimes I
was watching Aaron so I don't like third
down stuff let's just say he's
unbelievable I've never seen anything
like it it feels like you could hear him
coming if I'm a quarterback I might be
able to hear him yeah ya know our whole
deal on he's obviously extremely special
but our whole deal on because I don't
want to do is they close the pocket so
fast so fast and you know looking at
since the games this year they did
defensively in Seattle you know when
when they were when Reese was have a
part time you know in the pocket a
little bit was because of that I mean
they're so they're so so so fast to the
park and so fast and closing it that it
you know makes it easier going around
why was that turf so bad
at the culture yeah I don't know I don't
know you know I think I think it has to
do a little bit a little bit Dewey you
know I think it was a little bit humid
that night I saw you on the field and it
was new perhaps I don't know but you
know I think we were prepared for it I
don't think it was something that we
didn't expect what what kind of plans
for the offseason anything exciting no
nothing exciting it you know saying that
right now I think we saw come back start
training I'm sure I'll go home to the
area at some point to go on vacation
somewhere but nothing planned yet what
hurts on you right now geez much
actually I mean I was kind of talking
about after the game with my family like
I wish I was I wish I could play you
know four or five games and you know I
want to be miserable and I want to be
you know you know laying down like I
can't move and I just got beat up I
really don't feel that bad I just know
my body sometimes I take off for sure
but I really really don't have too much
so you let your team down because you
didn't get hit enough you didn't get
you're not enough pain is that you know
I wish I woulda got hit more if we're
gonna go out this way you know I wish
you a little bit more you know more of a
battle on my part I guess I don't know
just throw yourself down a flight of
stairs and then you know just start
limping and imputing and you got banged
up in a game against Atlanta huh who was
your favorite Rona and you know I grew
up in like the like the early 2000 era
the Niners so Jeff our ceilings guy was
like he was like these like my first
first memory of football and my first
memory of NFL football quarterback was
deaf person garrison Hearst and JJ
Stokes and you know TTL was even there
and and then in college so it was
probably Aaron being a Cal guy I was
each shelf and growing up and Watchers
was a guy there when I was growing up
did you ever talk to Rodgers when you
were at count
uh yeah everyone's well yeah briefly I
mean I talked to him in the past few
times yeah you know but no secrets no
secrets yeah like he didn't give you any
secrets on how to you know be a better
quarterback anything like that maybe if
you were in the AFC he would give you
some tips but now you're in the NFC yeah
did you know we were hoping that you got
to the Super Bowl for selfish reasons
because then you would have probably
worn DP show t-shirts around the entire
week I'm glad you got the the gift
package there no no I appreciate it I
had to reciprocate with yes I love that
but you got it washed before you sent it
because I thought that it was gonna
smell like Jadeveon Clowney and it you
washed it before you send it that's why
I made sure this is game on because I
didn't yeah we're we're framing it now
then we're gonna find room here in the
man cave but hey congrats it was season
it was great to follow and I know you're
disappointed but certainly a lot of
positives going into next season Thank
You Jared that's a Jared gone Rams
quarterback 28 touchdowns seven picks
threw for thirty eight hundred yards
quarterback rating if you're into that
was a hundred point five for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]